[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je m'appelle benjamin pas
cette année tp va devenir un peu plus
politique ça a commencé j'ai regardé
l'émission d'hier soir vous étiez tous
magnifiques on les applaudit s'il vous
plaît
j'aimerais vous présenter le conducteur
de tpm paix cette saison la bagarre avec
à 19h10 échauffement bagarre
19h40 bagarre tradi avec des gens du thé
qu'on va être un beau gars de fdp alors
on rappelle que fdp dans cette émission
n'est pas une insulte mais a rendez-vous
les flagueurs du pas d'ailleurs
connaissant cyril j'ai peur qu'à voir la
fin de la saison on donne les vraies
flammes aux chroniqueurs qui sert dessus
pour vous expliquer le principe de ce
rendez vous c'est très simple s'essayer
de réconcilier l irréconciliable par
exemple hier un vax face à nantes ivax
demain un vegan face à une entrecôte
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
14 dans cette présidentielle c'est qu'on
n'est même pas en septembre et il ya
déjà trop de candidats moi ça me
rappelle un jeu qui est-ce qui se
souvient de qui est-ce par exemple
est-ce qu'il est charismatique non c'est
xavier bertrand oui est-ce qu'il a un et
qui ressemble à une montgolfière oui
c'est jean lassalle bravo est ce qu'il
fait part aux enfants et aux musulmans
oui c'est eric zemmour j'écoute les
déclarations des candidats souvent ils
disent plein de gens m'ont dit tu
devrais y aller alors j'ai analysé cette
phrase et tout dépend du contexte tu
devrais y aller ça veut pas forcément
dire tu devrais aller à la
présidentielle
par exemple si vous êtes à une soirée
que quelqu'un vous dit écoute fabrice il
est une heure du matin ça fait quatre
ans que tu parles de pas salutaire tu
devrais y aller donc c'est un autre
contexte alors excusez moi monsieur
genton par exemple ça fait 3 heures vont
parler de vos baskets il est temps d'y
aller par exemple le contexte politique
n'est pas au beau fixe en france il
l'est encore moins en afghanistan
puisque les talibans ont repris le
contrôle de kaboul est aujourd'hui voici
un reportage exclusif sur un taliban
français qui a voulu rejoindre les
autres talibans à kaboul nous l'avons
suivi regarder ce magnéto
nous avons suivi abdel dit abou chelou
ce jeune talibans français a décidé de
rejoindre ses frères comme il dit est de
les aider dans la reconquête de
l'afghanistan fut là pour libérer avec
les frères ' la capitale de
l'afghanistan
cabourg
[Applaudissements]
rakim c'est kamel je suis arrivé à
kaboul un tout je sais pas vous êtes là
moi je vois pas de l'epagne mais non
frein mais t'avais dit cabourg mais
articule tard ashton
banhof pas kaboul à feu un peu plus loin
là
qu'un quiproquo un quiproquo
wayne lord in web dans leur jeter dit
charles à 13h en charles la plus 15
heures les dimanches
kaboul ces morts j'y arriverai jamais
pour les premières pendaison c'est
vendredi donc ce que je vais faire je
vais rester à cabourg et je vais libérer
cabourg voilà je vais recruter 2 3 mais
clan
des jeunes
voilà je m'appelle abdel mais sur les
réseaux sociaux jeux connus sous le nom
de la bouche l'eau est comme vous avoir
jeté gars et moi vous avez l'air égaré
toi tes gars et non non c est en fait
ouais il est arrivé dans ma vie par
l'intermédiaire d'alain et depuis j'ai
trouvé mon chum al hamdoullah et là j'ai
vraiment des missions ambitieuses avec
des sandales là comme vous c'est libérer
cabourg venez au liberia - c'est un
salaire bien en ont à [ __ ] là mes
frères je te parle d'un là tu me parles
de foot
c'est bien qu'un jour c'est l'offre
en france à kaboul à ma mère
bonjour ce en quoi
tu es musulman
tu es païenne ah ouais t'es pas
maintenant pas tu te raconte d'ouf
d'amis c'est ça le problème de
l'occident là les femmes qui vont à
l'école après douze ans la sam
desgouttes son genre une âme
ouais kaboul ces morts là j'ai un autre
plan mais je dois trouver la gare je
prends le train
j'ai le coeur fragile voix en soit on ne
laisse pas les gens dit elle en a marre
voir l'islam
trois frères change de religion vraiment
en tant qu'une qualification pour à tous
tout le monde connait soin de vous
[Musique]
on se trouvant sur mer
à bouche lou doit se rendre à l'évidence
il a échoué à libérer cabourg mais il
n'abandonne pas la lui il a décidé de
partir libérer la capitale de la syrie
si vous regardez ce sketch du côté de
kaboul c'est une idée de benjamin
castaldi merci
[Applaudissements]